freunde herzlich willkommen
mit hey was geht ab haben die ranken
sind bisschen gewachsen
dann müsste auch gewachsen seien von
unbestimmter dabei ich gibt besonders
gespannt jetzt wir müssen einmal hoch
klettern dann hier um die ecke die
renault
was habe ich die schere gehabt deren
hand ja man alles voll
obwohl wir hier nicht da ich erwarte ich
nehme ich erst mal die hier am rand weg
dann habe ich mich wieder zwei mehr
überall sind ein paar zu viele also du
kannst überall so ein paar abfischen ja
mach ich jetzt auch mal gerade eben du
wolltest erstmal wir haben nämlich vor
der folge wie wir das natürlich immer
tun uns die kommentare von euch gelesen
aber ich wollte erst halbwegs vorlesen
paar profi tipps sind richtig viele
zombies hier sind ich und ausland einer
mini zombie ich bin auf dem weg
alle getötet obwohl die zahl nicht
umsonst server
so also kommentare vorlesen
hier ist jetzt vom jan-peter mal ein
kommentar vor konkreter tipp an dich um
wenn ihr den hunger effekt habt bleibt
einfach so lange ruhig stehen
es kostet zwar nicht sehr viel zeit aber
es ist nützlich es kostet sehr viel zeit
meinte es kostet zwar sehr viele ja okay
dass gerade gesagt jetzt kostet zwar
nicht mehr viel zeit
ja ich bin ladins ich bin mir allerdings
wie sicher ob das stimmt also an hunger
hat wie ich jetzt gerade was stäbler
workers also wenn uwe tombini also ich
glaube er meint es so wenn man
verrottetes fleisch gegessen hat dann
hat man ja diesen hunger effekt links
und wenn man den hat soll man nicht
laufen sondern einfach mal stehen
bleiben ist es jetzt ich habe den 20
sekunden mal gucken wie sich das jetzt
auf meinen hunger ja es bringt nichts
ich hab schon ein halbes hundert keulen
teil vielleicht ein halbes kilogramm
verhungern lassen
das trikot wechseln es bringt doch
nichts mit dem stehen bleiben ich hab
trotzdem was verloren ist der masterplan
ab wir brauchen unbedingt mal einen plan
und wir brauchen was zu fressen
abgestellt die kommentare form wir
einmal erde kriegen würden ein
verdammtes mal oder wir brauchen wir
brauchen halt wirklich eine schief dann
können wir dieses portal steam play down
weil wir das haben wir ja schon und
danach bin ich mir sehr sicher dass wir
dann nach erde bekommen irgendwie da bin
ich mir sehr sicher
und ja wir haben schon in purple saint
clair
die sache ist jetzt halt dass wir
irgendwie noch ein schiff mit brauchen
das darauf zu setzen sollten bei den
events was wir da machen könnten
brot backen können nicht pro pack
wir haben einhalten wir brauchen ja echt
erde und samen
was gibt's da noch mit yoga marken
ex-porsche-chef wie diamanten finden
oder zum beispiel auch eine truhe also
ich meine nach oben ist ja noch viel
offen
so würde ich ihn weil wir immer
ertrunken virtuellen skelett töten das
kommt wahrscheinlich wieder am ende
irgendwann denke ich schon kugelfisch
der diamond halten da müssen wir jetzt
hat diamanten gucken oder halt einfach
mal weiter nach oben gehen doch einfach
nach oben weil da sind doch diese wasser
tunnel wo wir immer daran verzweifelt
man rüstung machen weil wir haben so
eine heißen nee nee auf keinen fall kein
jurist zu machen würde ich niemals
machen wir im truck mit sprungkraft
krass die sache ist halt dass wir
dauerhaft sind quasi ja ich könnte mich
deswegen mal eben schnell aber eine
rüstung bringt da wirklich nicht viel
aber wie ich denke mal so diese ganzen
schönen level die wir haben die inhalte
flöten ja so ist das manchmal muss man
schon mal im leben sagen
und da fehlten weiterer toller tipp
wichtig bei circa 145 seht ihr eure
items im wasserfall ganz links ja ganz
links max ist also in dem links neben
dem todesort vor dem boss so das bringt
jetzt auch nichts sowohl in der linken
kiste sind meine sachen unten hingelegt
da habe ich meine auch eine sind
sortiert sein
dahinter kann ich hab meinen unten
hingelegt ich stelle übrigens gerade
auch mal 800 skeledzic wasserpistole
skeledzic wir haben übrigens auch habe
ich nochmal durchlesen wir sollten auf
keinen fall diesen quatsch blog abbauen
der da oben wo wir halt mal drauf spawn
das heißt wir müssen auch aufpassen dass
da kein krieg an die luft geht
ich bin mir nicht sicher vielleicht ist
der blog auch irgendwie so verankert
dass man da das akw keinen krieg doch
explodieren kann
ich bin ich sicher so dürfen auf jeden
fall auf kleinsten den block zu
zerstören ich mache mir mal eben noch
eine spitzhacke beobachters aber ich
glaube ich mache eine aus eisen eine aus
steinen und ich hab mal geschaut
also noch unten können wir uns auch
nicht weiterbauen das heißt wir müssen
immer nach oben nach unten gibt es nicht
gibt nicht wirklich nicht weiter will
weil ich das nur bedrock also da würden
wir uns wirklich einer wand den kopf
kaputt schlagen dann wieder rauskommen
würden wollen aber man das ist alles ein
bisschen nicht so hab ich weiß was ich
mache wir gehen jetzt auch erstmal ich
hab noch zwei rampen und die packt
erstmal dann stehen hier aber egal
kommen wir müssen jetzt mal endlich ihr
diamanten sowie das hallo was sind das
auch für räume sind ja immer so eisen
räumen und auch das noch ein traum so
aber wo steht jetzt noch mal der amboss
ich bin einmal dran vorbei gelaufen ich
finds echt langsam boston war es um
weiterzukommen eigentlich nicht eben
doch nicht weil wieder
gar nicht rankommen aber sobald er
nämlich nehmen hier immer noch so ein
paar rannten mit immer gemacht das in
uns haben uns haben wie dieser
generieren auch gar nicht wenn wir nicht
wie ein capped ist zwei diesen diesen
luxus das wäre quasi wenn man
irgendwelche suppen dabei haben oder so
das war so schön und du bist ja wirklich
sicher dass ein amboss gesehen hast
irgendwo hier bestimmt hier unter den
blöcken sicherlich stimmt komme aber
doch doch der war ein abbruch durch
darabos runde ab dem 1
ich gesagt dass der bus ist es ganz
schön wollen wir da einfach weiter nach
einer langen nacht oder nie wir könnten
uns doch einfach mal noch holz machen
und dann in die kiste hier schauen heißt
du aber da waren wir schon mal trendy
wir waren an den kisten hier oben glaube
ich oder menschen kann auch seiner
forschen wann sie kommt wir gehen jetzt
einfach mal hoch da waren wir schon mal
wir müssen irgendwie weiter nach oben
kommen wäre eben keiner ist gestorben
hier findet ihr hier stimmt deswegen
sieht auch alles kaputt ja und so kaputt
aus durch den körper nämlich zwischen
kriminalität ertrunken wir müssen da
wohl irgendwie hoch womit man wirklich
auch und luftanhalten 8 durch
hmm
da wartet ruhe wird richtig heftig
renken richtig heftig stirb genau da wo
er wieder eine hat ich habe nichts
gesehen
acom bekomme wo bist du bist doch hat
unten bringen redstone fackel mit
man ist schon zu spät dann hol dich
jetzt und zwar wir brauchen auf jeden
fall direkt an fackel da hab ich ja noch
gar nicht dran gedacht bei der attacke
kam er unter wasser atmen oder nur
normale facto geht doch auch oder
ich glaub mir redstone fackel abstimmen
die unterwasser brands natur gefunden
die sah richtig heftig aus david und ich
nehme auch mal eine truhe mit eventuell
haben wir das ja um erkundet ich hab'
ich kann ja nicht regenerieren so wenig
leben habe ich hier
hier oben ist wir sind hinten fisch du
meinst einen guardian
denkbar seien tina fey stadt hängen mit
mal so jo einfahrt der angst vor
dauerhaften ausstieg zehnten fisch man
so ja ich bin jetzt wieder bei dir
übrigens ein echtes ziel verfolgt mich
unheimlich cook nach unten dachte so ich
war ich ja den namen gesucht habe und
plötzlich kommt er dieser komische
tintenfisch ich habe dabei getroffen mit
dem fall
ich bin meiner höhle hier aber ich will
sterben
wenn ich irgendwo trassen heftigen fall
mit diesem guardian junge ich hab den
guardian jedoch nicht erlebt noch was
ist das denn für ein scheiß viel er ist
auch richtig stärke na ja ich komme mal
wieder hoch als treffen nicht mal der
ist halt wirklich richtig stark dann
blockt in meinem fall auch ab
robert ist sehr stark aber ich habe ihn
getötet ich habe ihn getötet kannst
hochkommt und krieg mehr auf den weg ich
brauch gleich von dir einmal die
redstone fackel und einmal eine
spitzhacke noch nicht reingeguckt des
links da sind einfach nur boote drin und
ein battle day light sensor wo ich
dachte schon mal schießen kann ich
einmal kurz die die fackel und all die
spitzhacke weil ich muss ganz nach oben
und meine sachen retten
ich geb dir wird und auch weil niemand
die tasten ich habe außerdem bot gegeben
das boot zurück i bring ich die sachen
schon runter und hoffe dass ich sterbe
weil wir hier schon wieder so viel
schlafen da hab ich ein bisschen angst
verlieren irgendwie so war sie leider
auch mit der fackel
ich hoffe ich sterbe nicht auf dem weg
alter ich habe einfach auch sonnen
jetzt jedoch ich hab's geschafft
ich fühle mich mal so sicher wenn ich
unten in unserer pace bin aber das war
also wo ich lust gelaufen bin da war
noch richtig viele monster bei unserer
welt ich habe immer wieder von unseren
preis marion schardt bekommen von dem
guardian
so ich habe zwei feilen und ich meine
sachen wieder und ich hab ne party
wollte ich schon sagen mit ruhe gefunden
mit werbung der nacht sich zwei stück
dann verzaubertes buch wasserläufer zwei
wofür auch immer dann ein eisbad und
ganz viele press marien kristalle hast
du bekommen
jo ok kohleverbrauch mir dass alles das
frage ich nicht bei allen sachen die wir
irgendwie hier zu kriegen also auf der
seite von captain minecraft rider war
noch tipps die müssen wir uns vielleicht
auch mal durchgelesen hatte wenig auf
einen gemeinsamen nenner mit dem hübner
geworden ich weil ich aber auch schon
die ganze zeit das einzige was wir
machen können ist diamanten schauen
aber wie wollen wir das machen wir haben
so ein hungerproblem wir haben echt ich
habe noch nie so einen hunger problem
dachte mal deswegen immer weiter nach
oben und schauen ob wir irgendwann mal
glück haben mit
ich kann mich da die direkt schon wieder
umbringen ich mache das jetzt auch ich
werde hier gerade umgebracht ich habe
mir übrigens meine eigene kiste eben
justizpalast eine eigene kiste geholt
die ich hier weg ist so weit sind wir
schon nicht mehr abgeben kann also soll
ich dass man sterben
münster ein skelett genug im alter noch
einer hier ist gar nicht safe und dann
immer noch nein ich mache jetzt richtig
meint richtig ruhig aber eher noch zwei
jahre als elfter und unsere pace und
unsere pace finde ich immer relativ safe
co
hofmann wir brauchen einen plan wir
brauchen einen festen plan job wir
können hier theoretisch mal durch gucken
wir sind diese leuchten hier ist wasser
da ist neben mir steht auch noch so eine
leuchte jäger
du bist bei mir steht oder flasche
ich habe hier drei roten vielleicht für
dich total
danke danke ich bringe mich jetzt um
nicht war das jetzt bitte ich sag nicht
durstig
die blöcke sehr gut sei es ein schöner
weg hast du toll gemacht tolle deutsche
arbeit hier
ich mache jetzt alles wieder auf die
brücke wieder aus wie neu ja was ist das
da hinten eigentlich tipptopp lange
serie bekomme so aufnehmen
jetzt wo er kommt so eine flagge
erst wollte ich dir vor insider müssen
nach oben laufen konnte
ich hab das schwert alter echte trojanow
bord das ist ein longboard online
creeper blauer farbverlauf schwarzer
farbverlauf gar nix mehr
schwarzes hier nochmal voll komisch ist
deutsch schwarzes banner steht bei mir
an pale blue crane black rain bereich
sales trading cup diese neuen klang die
alten blackberry hinzugefügt werden
mit der anfang habe ich würde sagen das
wasser wieder mit erfolgen habe nichts
erreicht in der nächsten folge mache war
damals ein bisschen erkundung da oben
da reicht wieder was dann kommt die
verquickung auf den kanälen und in dem
man in der nächsten folge wieder wegen
meiner lieben wille tepper die sich
vergessen es ja immer wieder geschickt